this episode of the wi files is brought
to you by
Shopify you wake up sleepiness Fades as
your eyes slowly open to a bright white
light and it feels warm and familiar it
feels like home and your whole family is
there to meet you your entire life
flashes before your eyes like scenes
from a movie The Good The Bad even the
awful things you've done but everything
comes together it finally makes sense
with this enormous weight off your
shoulders the memory of your life starts
to fade just like a dream a familiar
voice says we're happy you're here we
missed you but you can't stay what you
just got here you're getting kicked out
already the voice says they need you but
we'll see you again when the time is
right and you know somehow the voice is
telling the truth suddenly a burst of
RedHot pain rips through your chest it
feels like every single cell in your
body is on fire you can't breathe a
scream forces your eyes open it's a
blood curdling scream like an animal
being eaten alive then you realize the
scream is coming from you you're in a
hospital bed surrounded by doctors and
nurses they all take a step back stunned
they're staring at you but why well you
just came back from the
[Music]
dead yeah I I no I know I wasn't
driving I get it I know I I'll pay for
the
damages ah human oh uh hey I uh I dorsal
fin dialed you I'll catch you on the
flip hold on a minute crap so uh what's
new with you is there anything you want
to tell me uh uh thank you for giving
Gertie those hump wers for Christmas
that was very thoughtful of you are we
just going to pretend that I didn't open
my garage this morning and find you
Gertie and the Beaver Brothers and about
a th000 boxes oh it's just for a little
while don't get your penes in award you
let the Beaver Brothers drive my car
they found it a block away on someone's
lawn hey Wyatt is a fantastic driver but
I admit Morgan has a bit of a lead por
and it reminds me can you call in a
favor with the PD and get a speeding
ticket handled I I I think we're getting
off topic what are you doing in my
garage well I seen how great the merch
in a wi files online store is so I
decided to start my own merch business
Heckle M so for right now I got a sell
out of a garage my garage oh you say
potato anyhoo it's just until sales take
off and I can open my own brick and mor
Warehouse why don't you just use Shopify
oh I got the sneaking suspicion that
that is today's sponsor lucky for you it
is we run the wi file store through
Shopify it's an all-in-one Commerce
platform that anyone can use we've been
using Shopify for years they helped us
build out our online store and track
everything no camels or beavers needed
with Shopify you can take a product and
sell it online across all social media
platforms even in person millions of
businesses in 175 countries trust
Shopify as a business partner but I
don't know how any of that stuff works
I'm not technical my VCR is still
blinking 12:00 half of the audience is
not even going to understand what the
why do you still have a VCR it was a
wedding gift so I'm sentimental about it
it reminds me of happier days
your marriage my divorce never mind
Shopify makes it easy they have tools
for new merchants and great marketing
tools Shopify can even help with Banking
and capital sounds perfect sign me up
just go to shopify.com slthe files or
click on the QR code shopify.com theey
files or the QR code you got it now can
you please remove all those boxes from
my garage what are you selling anyway H
you know not major just some old stuff
we had lying around the studio uh we
don't have any old stuff around the
studio are those head shots that I sign
for wi files fans I don't sell those
well maybe you don't but I got a
business to run no you can't wait does
Virgil have my underwear Virgil I told
you socks and underwears have to go and
zip lock bags to seal in the freshness
you better not be selling got orders to
pack got to
[Music]
go
you've heard me say this before all
cultures have a flood myth whether it's
religious like Noah's flood or cultural
like the chocked on Native American
flood story they all got them since
every culture has a flood myth many
scientists no longer think it's just a
story The Flood myth was probably an
actual historical event and just like
the flood myth every religion and
culture on Earth has a story of the
afterlife and the more consistent the
story The more likely it is to be true
most religions and cultures attach a
social aspect to the afterlife ancient
Egyptians believed in auu or the field
of reads Ah that's the one with Kevin C
it in a corn right no that was Field of
Dreams ah right they saw it as if you
build it they will come could you let me
get through this sorry I couldn't resist
the reference continue Egyptians saw auu
as the perfect world an idealized
version of how we live today here your
soul was granted Eternal Paradise but
only if you passed the test when your
soul first leaves your body Anubis
appears beside you he then guides you
from your tomb to wait on the line of
souls yeah it sounds more like the DMV
Than Paradise please don't now serving
so B 125 so b125 please go to window 11
for
processing you were given water and
comforted by other deities as the line
got shorter and shorter when it was your
turn you were led to the hall of Truth
this is where Osiris to and Maat weighed
your heart on the scales of Justice if
your soul was virtuous your heart would
be very light it would need to be it's
weighed against the feather of Maat the
goddess of Truth and Justice you were
deemed Unworthy of paradise if your
heart was heavier than the feather then
amut would eat your heart amut was a
part lion crocodile hippopotamus monster
if you were virtuous you or more
specifically your soul was free to enter
auu if the story of Journey and judgment
sounds familiar it's because the same
story is told in almost all major
religions while you await judgment
there's usually a holding area for
Catholics it's Purgatory Inuits and some
Native American tribes describe a long
road which they see as The Milky Way in
ancient greas before your soul reached
the underworld you had to cross the
river sticks and board I'm the captain
so climb aboard we'll search for
tomorrow on every Shore and I'll try oh
Lord I'll
try that's know enough okay okay take it
easy I wasn't going to be able to hit
that next note anyway I'm not sure you
hit any of those
notes when we've passed the holding area
our souls are judged based on how we
lived our life on Earth with the help of
deities like St Peter we do a sort of
Life review if we've lived good lives
we're gifted a pleasurable afterlife if
we've lived poorly or outside the bounds
of religious or cultural norms were sent
to the bad place either to learn from
our mistakes or to suffer for
eternity not every religion works this
way though in Buddhism souls are
reincarnated over and over again live a
good life and in the next one you'll get
an upgrade live a bad life and your next
life will be more difficult once you
live a life free from desire attachment
and ignorance you can escape the cycle
of reincarnation and reach nirvana see
now here's where I would break into a
little Smells Like Teen Spirit but it's
too soon for another musical break thank
God for small favors with the light do
here we
arey most atheists will tell you there's
nothing after death just the black void
but most people including myself feel
there's something more something waiting
for us on the other side for almost all
of human history there is no way to
prove the existence of an afterlife we'd
have to bring someone back from the dead
to do that but death is final right
nope in 1943 young army recruit George G
Richie was left unattended in an
isolation room for 24 hours he'd been
brought in with an extreme case of
pneumonia because no one treated him
George died he was only 20 years old the
medical staff gathered around his
lifeless body they were devastated and
worried about Fallout George's death
could have been avoided one medical
officer pulled a sheet over George's
face and officially called his time of
death the officer instructed an
attendant to prepare George's body for
the morg and everyone left the room 9
minutes later the attendant returned in
the corner of his eye he noticed
something was George's chest moving well
it couldn't be they checked his Vital
Signs multiple times and nothing still
something didn't feel quite right the
attendant checked again George was dead
but for whatever reason the attendant
still had an odd feeling that something
was off George was given a shot of
adrenaline George woke up with a bang he
sat right up and got on his feet he was
drowsy but fully recovered from
pneumonia the only thing on his mind was
returning to Virginia to finish his Army
Medical Training while George was on his
way back he stopped at a small town to
ask for directions but everyone he spoke
to just ignored him like he was
invisible but what was this beeping
noise ringing over and over again in
George's ear it wasn't there when he
began the journey how did he begin the
journey again he was flying or was he
driving he couldn't remember the beeping
was getting louder until it turned into
a deafening Roar it was medical
equipment George was training to be a
medic and he knew the sound was from a
heart monitor George never left the
hospital he was lying in the same bed he
died in Just 4 days earlier the
adrenaline kick started his heart and he
started breathing again though George
was officially dead for quite a while he
made a full recovery in 1965 George told
his story to one of his postgraduate
Psychiatry students a man named Raymond
moody moody was fascinated so much that
he dedicated the rest of his career to
figuring out what happens on the other
side I don't mind saying that after
talking with over a thousand people who
have had these experiences and having
experienced many times some of the
really baffling and unusual features of
these experiences it has given me great
confidence that there is a life after
after death as a matter of fact I must
confess to you in all honesty I have
absolutely no doubt on the basis of what
my patients have told me that they did
get a glimpse of the
Beyond Moody called this phenomenon a
near-death experience or nde coining the
term in his 1975 book Life After Life
his work inspired countless others to
collect massive amounts of data on
people who technically died but were
revived one of these researchers is Dr
Michael sabom who's written several
books on ndes saam's Research is where
things start to get interesting sabom
interviewed people who'd suffered
Cardiac Arrest died and claimed to have
had an outof body experience in nde
these patients were asked to describe
their resuscitation what was happening
in the room who was there what sounds
did they recall the patients answers
were compared to those of a control
group who had also suffered card CC
crisis and were revived but without
temporary death patients in the control
group gave vague mostly incorrect
answers they were guessing what happened
to them they didn't really know but the
nde group they described the
resuscitations almost perfectly like
they were in the room separate from
their bodies watching themselves come
back to life the accuracy was enough for
sabom to conduct further studies and
like Raymond Moody sabam inspired others
to repeat his research if multiple
researchers independently conduct
similar or exactly the same experiment
and they all find the same results then
it's hard to refute the truth this is
precisely what happened with sabom study
over the years researchers have asked
thousands of patients to describe events
surrounding their ndes and despite being
dead these patients are roughly 92 to
97% accurate in their observations
doctors and nurses have also come
forward with some pretty spooky stories
Dr Carl Green are neurosurgeon had a
patient Flatline and then describe her
entire surgery down to the most
intricate details and green is not alone
patients often have outof body
experiences during surgeries where they
temporarily die this happened to my
dad my pop loved Harley's dad's first
wreck a teenage girl ran a stop sign she
hit him Square his leg was severed and
reattached Mamas Don't let your babies
grow up to be bikers almost 20 years
later an SUV ran a light hit him Square
same side this time was worse way
worse dad was airlifted from the scene
and died in the
helicopter they defied him and brought
him back but he lost so much blood they
didn't think he'd make it to the
hospital he did but just barely during
surgery he flatlined
again he said he felt weightless and
realized he was watching his operation
but then he felt a pull he turned and
saw his mother who had been gone a long
time he said Mom I hurt real bad I can't
do it she said yes you can it's not your
time yet they got Dad's heart started
again and brought him
back he said the experience was more
real than real life
but sometimes people do more than just
float a few feet above their bodies some
people have described events that took
place down the hall from their deathbed
or in a different room in the hospital
so not only do our souls have weight
they stick around to watch our physical
bodies die and we don't just stay in the
room we wander and while we wander we're
not
[Music]
alone almost all n e follow a similar
pattern it starts with the sensation of
absolute peace and calm as you enter a
bright white light through the light you
enter a tunnel and your physical body is
Left Behind in 1791 British Admiral Sir
Francis bort almost drowned after he was
revived he described a feeling as in his
words the most perfect Tranquility he
felt no bodily pain his physical senses
were gone but his mind was very active
the Admiral saw his life pass before his
eyes in reverse this is a common theme
in nde your life plays either in Reverse
chronological order or starts from your
birth until your death once the show is
over you see yourself completely really
for the first time ever and then you
move on and on the other side people are
waiting for you Dr Mary Neil drowned
while kayaking in Chile she was
technically dead for 30 minutes long
enough for her body to turn blue before
being pulled from the
water and then I was released to the
heavens my spirit rose up and out of the
river and I was immediately greeted by a
group of people or spirits who had known
me and loved me as long as I have
existed seeing people on the other side
is almost always a positive experience
Minister Don Piper was driving home to
Alvin Texas one night and was hit by an
18wheeler in a head-on collision his
body became part of the car actually his
thigh bone ended up somewhere on the
road behind him as he entered the white
light loved ones also met him they were
waiting for him next to a large ornate
gate and it wasn't a short trip Don
spent 30 Minutes in Heaven in the west
most people describe what is essentially
heaven after they die but just like all
ancient cultures everyone interprets
their experience based on their personal
biases and background a Christian will
say he saw Jesus in heaven an atheist
will enter something like a bright white
ether Muslims go to Janna while there
there's something or someone with us
Emory was a first year law student who
liked fast cars after lying to her
parents and boyfriend about what she was
doing she went out driving with friends
halfway through the drive she had a
sudden urge to go home her friends
agreed but on the way there was an
accident Emory's body was thrown through
the windshield she got to her feet
covered in blood and walked over to
where her friend were sitting she felt
like she'd been unconscious and had the
strangest dreams she asked her friends
what was happening but no one would
speak her parents pulled up a short
while later and even though paramedics
tried to stop him Em's father was
running she followed his gaze and
realized he was running toward a body
She chased after him he was on his knees
sobbing over her Emory was
dead between his tears her father said
why are you doing this out of no nowhere
a voice replied this was the agreement
Em's father said no it wasn't the
agreement was that I would watch them
grow old but never lived to experience
this emry knew her father wasn't having
this conversation out loud it was
happening in his subconscious he didn't
even know he was speaking it was his
soul speaking to someone The Voice
started to disappear into a place she
couldn't quite see but emry knew it was
there she tried to follow it the voice
was so calming and peaceful but her
world was slowly fading to
Black the next time she woke up she was
in the ICU thousands of people have had
ndes you can get lost for hours reading
about them online they sound Serene life
altering usually in a good
way I'm Don Piper and I died on January
18th
1989 Don Piper says he was depressed for
a long time after he came back to life
but in time he realized how valuable
dying had been to him to his soul he
felt saved especially knowing we're
never actually alone but you can't just
go and have a near-death experience
whenever you want to an nte requires a
certain type of permission because not
everyone goes into the light some people
go somewhere
else Howard storm woke up in his
hospital bed it was 1985 he was in Paris
with his wife on what he thought was a
romantic vacation even though he just
invited her on a college field trip for
his students but that was Howard he
didn't really get romance he'd always
been a difficult man he was rarely happy
quick to anger and in many ways he'
taken after his father who was
aggressive when Howard was young
Howard's anger was with him in his
hospital bed he was annoyed at his wife
for closing the curtains and why was she
just sitting there crying at the foot of
the bed what reason did she have to be
sad this wasn't happening to her her a
few hours ago Howard was screaming in
agony due to a perforated intestine at
the hospital Howard was told he needed
surgery immediately otherwise he'd be
dead within 5
hours somehow the hospital lost track of
him he laay there for 10 hours his body
slowly digesting itself but he felt a
lot better now still angry just
healthier and he wanted some sunlight
and some fresh air he got to his feet
and went to open the windows but
something was wrong wrong his wife was
still ignoring him he could feel
something radiating off her like an
energy field of Rage that he'd never
seen before what does she have to be sad
and angry about Howard kept asking
himself but he couldn't deal with her
right now so he went into the hallway to
find a doctor to give them a piece of
his mind as he turned the corner into
the hallway a sensation hid him he was
never going back in that hospital room
not ever again he didn't know how he
knew this he just did the hallway was
dark Howard could see dim flick licking
but something was blocking the light as
he focused he saw them faceless beings
dressed in black robes at the sight of
them he fell to the ground everything
felt heavy he knew these beings whatever
they were were here for him and they
were dragging him back to Hell remember
that scene in ghost it was just like
that
I prefer Roadhouse please no zingers
while I'm being dramatic sorry
Miho the dim lights got dimmer and
dimmer until Howard was in pure Darkness
he heard a voice say we're almost there
suddenly the darkness lifted and Howard
was in a vast hellscape filled with
Horrors even nightmares couldn't create
there were humanoid looking monsters
ripping him
apart but were you experiencing pain
while this was happening yeah and it was
horrible it was I mean it was horrible
being literally being torn
apart Howard didn't believe in God he
did as a kid but grew out of it but he
was desperate and prayed for help and
help arrived Howard was pulled out of
the darkness and into the light he was
shown his life which was a
disappointment and a
failure Howard you're watching your life
literally as a movie before you
absolutely and not only did I see my
life but I could also see like my
mother's feelings and how how
I how I hurt her I never wanted to hurt
my mother Howard wanted to stay in this
place where he felt nothing but kindness
compassion and love but he was told he
had to go back and make things right
then his soul returned to his body very
few near-death experiences take place in
hell but those who end up there often
follow a similar path in the leadup to
death there is an emotional trauma
sometimes it's drug abuse alcoholism
self-abuse or just being a terrible
person like Howard people describe being
lost wandering a desolate landscape they
hear endless screams some come from
creatures that look like they were human
once but no longer descriptions of Hell
sound similar to the ancient Egyptian
process of death they walked through the
Hall of truths to be judged their hearts
were weighed and their hearts were
devoured if they're really is a hell as
described by so many cultures and
religions that's a terrifying thought it
makes me worry about how heavy my heart
will be compared to a feather but
Skeptics will argue that's the point
they say religions and ancient rulers
invented the concept of Heaven and Hell
maintaining order in societies of
thousands and millions of people is
difficult if people believe in Hell
they'll behave and be easier to control
since mcdougall's 21 GS experiment
researching death has been taboo so
there aren't a lot of scientific studies
that try to explain what happens after
we die but that would change with a
study published in May of this year a
group of scientists measured and mapped
the brain activity of dying patients
they proved that after the body shuts
down completely the brain becomes more
alive than
ever scientists haven't figured out how
our brains work we know what parts of
our brain light up when we're engaged in
different activities but we don't know
how or why this happens what energy
source forms our thoughts and feelings
and memories and reactions scientists
are still trying to figure out does cell
activity produce the mind or does the
Mind create cell activity and what is
the human mind are Minds just another
way of describing our souls is our soul
Consciousness are they the same thing or
are they separate and when we die does
our Consciousness die but our soul lives
on nobody really knows in May 2023 a
study was published in the proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences Dr
jimo borin and her teams study
Consciousness they wanted to know what's
the minimum process required to create
Consciousness in our physical
brain the study involved four patients
who were in comas and on life support
and nearing the end these patients were
chosen because while they weren't fully
brain dead they were completely
unresponsive to any stimuli there's a
scale used to assess a person's level of
Consciousness after a head injury it's
called The Glass galoma score these four
patients had the lowest score possible
all of them had severe brain injuries
with the permission of their families
these four people's brains were scanned
as they were taken off life support
while in a coma their brain scans look
like this the left side of the chart is
brain wave frequency the bottom number
indicates the number of seconds left
before the patient dies red indicates
High brain activity and orange indicates
less activity then green then blue is no
activity so a comos patient on life
support has activity mainly at the lower
frequencies this is autonomic motor
function functions like breathing
heartbeat and hormone regulation
basically the things the body does on
its own Consciousness on the other hand
occurs at higher frequencies so the
patients were taken off life support and
something strange happened that
surprised the
scientists W there is a sudden surge in
brain activity at the higher frequencies
remember the body is now shutting down
the heart and lungs have stopped but the
brain is lighting up something is
happening to this patient about 10
minutes before brain death there's
suddenly more activity across the entire
spectrum and then for a few seconds a
spike highly active brain activity then
the activity settles down again so it's
easy to dismiss this Spike as an anomaly
maybe some randomly firing neurons are
freaking out that there's no Oxygen
getting to the brain anymore but then
this happens W the patient's entire
brain lights up very high activity
across the Spectrum this patient has
been medically dead for 12 or 13 minutes
but their brain is fully alive and
engaged again a skeptic might say this
is just random neurons desperately
clinging to life but that's not what's
happening at all only specific parts of
the patient's brain were active the
scientists saw activity in their somat
sensory cortex and the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex oh any idiot would
have told you that would happen are you
being s of course I'm being sarcastic
explain to the people about the Tomato
sensory tomato sensory what I say the
somato sensory cortex processes
information from your senses like touch
pressure pain and temperature this part
of the brain even processes
proprioception which senses your body's
position this part of the brain is
activated when engaging in physical
activities like sports and exercising
where your body needs to be aware of its
position movement and balance it's
active when using fine motor skills like
writing typing drawing or playing a
musical instrument this patient is dead
yet their brain is acting like their
body is engaged in physical activity
like floating above the bed walking down
a tunnel right and the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex that part of the brain
is used for problem solving and
decision-making it assesses risk weighs
pros and cons and considers different
outcomes this is also the part of the
brain used for language and
communication and more than simple
communication the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex is used to construct
complex ideas and engage in debate this
patient's brain this dead patient's
brain is engaged in highly complicated
thought and reasoning as well as
physical motion but what was it the
brain activity wasn't random it was
organized and specific scans showed
messages were being sent back and forth
to the patient's posterior cerebral
cortex researchers believe this area of
the brain is required for conscious
perception Visual and Sound Processing
understanding spoken language and
integrating sensory information and
movement these patterns are almost
identical to what we see in healthy
brains that are dreaming this is also a
pattern similar to epileptics who have
an outof Body Experience not only were
these patients dead but they died with
brain damage and there was no brain
activity before life support was
disconnected none but for a few minutes
after death their brains lit up like
Time Square finally brain activity slows
and then about 5 minutes later it
completely
stops but for about 3 minutes this
previously comos now medically deceased
person had an extremely Vivid conscious
experience and showed no sign of brain
damage at all in their mind their body
was moving their senses were engaged
they could smell they could feel touch
they were seeing and hearing something
they were having a conversation with
someone and that takes us back to the
beginning the big question who are they
talking
to
is there a scientific explanation for
near-death experiences or is something
Supernatural at work near-death
experiences are described the same way
in every culture and have been since the
beginning of recorded history common
features include floating above your
body traveling through a tunnel toward a
bright light feelings of bliss
communicating with spirits and seeing
long deceased loved ones no matter the
culture the religion or lack of religion
ndes are a universal Human
Experience this could be because they is
an afterlife and we do have a soul or
the experiences are similar because our
brains are built the same way the most
widely accepted scientific theory is
that ndes are hallucinations that happen
as brain cells begin to die from lack of
oxygen this is called the dying brain
hypothesis this could explain why so
many ndes share common Supernatural
elements they may be byproducts of the
brain's final burst of activity when
your brain isn't getting enough oxygen
you experience tunnel vision as your
optic nerve fails this could be why so
many people describe a tunnel Pilots
undergoing intense acceleration have
reported tunnel vision and bright light
as oxygen drops in a dying brain neurons
fire in Cascades that could be perceived
as bright light this happened to Neil
Armstrong during GeForce training for
the Apollo Mission people who get panic
attacks experience tunnel vision tunnel
vision feeling lightheaded numbness in
the extremities that's what my panic
attacks are like but those effects are
nothing more than the brain I getting
enough oxygen which is why taking deep
breaths helps well most of the time lack
of oxygen also causes hallucinations now
when Mountaineers climb the Himalayas
they bring oxygen with them but that
wasn't always the case in 1933 Frank SMI
was high on Mount Everest higher than
anyone had ever been before he stopped
to rest he offered half his food to His
companion but then realized he was
climbing alone all the time I was
climbing alone I had a strong feeling
that I was a companied by a second
person that feeling was so strong that
it completely eliminated all loneliness
I might otherwise have felt there's also
a type of epilepsy that can cause ndes
it's temporal lobe epilepsy the temporal
lobe of the brain is crucial in
processing emotions memory and is also
involved in the formation of the
conscious self in studies stimulating
this region of the brain has triggered
outof body experiences similar to those
reported in ndes then there are the
chemical changes there are fluctuations
in dopamine and serotonin these
chemicals cause feelings of happiness
and peace there's a release of
endorphins this also causes a feeling of
Peace plus endorphins are a natural
painkiller it's been suggested that NN
dimethyl tryptamine or DMT is released
in our brains upon birth and upon death
DMT is a powerful psychedelic Skeptics
say these chemicals likely contribute to
nd's dreamlike Quality but with all due
respect to to the Skeptics a DMT
experience is nothing like an nde I know
this firsthand when someone is having a
near-death experience they're very aware
of their conscious self DMT also called
The Spirit Molecule detaches you from
your ego it's hard to explain you feel
like you're disconnected from everything
and connected to everything at the same
time and by the way if you're thinking
of trying DMT for fun don't do that it's
not fun and what about the weight of the
human soul we proved it weighs 21 GRS
right well no yes maybe everything about
mcdougall's experiment is true but he
only worked with six patience the
experiment lacked proper controls and
hasn't been successfully replicated okay
so what happened with more recent 21 G
experiment what results did those
scientists get well we don't know
nobody's tried to replicate it why not
if science could prove the existence of
the Soul it would be one of the most
important discoveries in human history
but that discovery would also be
extremely
[Music]
dangerous the fact scientists won't
repeat mcdougall's 21 GS experiment
annoys me but it doesn't surprise me
when McDougall was conducting his study
the owners of the home were worried the
church would find out and be furious
when his results were released the
opposite happened scientists were
Furious not the church the church was
thrilled McDougall had proven the
existence of a soul he was one step
closer to proving the existence of God
but to this day many scientists laugh at
mcdougall's results calling them utterly
false okay prove it maybe McDougall
didn't prove there is a soul but nobody
can prove there
isn't science says when our brains stop
working there's nothing happening we're
just dead but recent studies like the
one we talked about today proves there
is something happening science just
doesn't know what and when science
doesn't have the answer religion often
does does but governments have been
trying to destroy religion all religions
for the last 150
years in doing so the state has become a
religion for millions of people don't
believe me spend 10 minutes on X Twitter
it's X now I'm not calling it that it's
stupid I don't
disagree if science were to conclusively
prove the existence of the human soul
that would virtually eliminate the need
for the military-industrial complex it
would eliminate the need for a
militarized police force we'd finally
know for sure what our purpose is to be
virtuous good kind generous to help our
fellow people navigate and survive this
crazy world if we knew for certain that
the soul could go to hell well you'd see
a pretty big drop in violent crime in
all crime and any would be dictators out
there would think twice before seizing
power there is no scientific proof of a
soul and an afterlife there is evidence
mounting evidence but evidence isn't
proof but do we really need proof if
you're a person of Faith you don't you
already know there's a God in heaven
awaits and I'm envious of those people
but what about those of us who aren't
religious I consider myself very
practical I'd love scientific proof of
an afterlife but what I find very
strange is I don't really need it I have
a sense deep down that there's something
more I think most of us do but maybe
that's just the way we evolved we're
aware that our own death is inevitable
we need a mechanism to keep us from
freaking out believing in an afterlife
is that mechanism that tells us not to
worry that everything's going to be okay
I'm glad that mechanism is there but I
can't help but wonder if someone put it
there recent Studies have shown that
when a person dies their cells don't
start decaying immediately they remain
in a state of hibernation for quite a
few
minutes that doesn't seem like an
accident to me it seems like it's by
Design it's as if during those few
minutes of hibernation we're waiting for
permission from someone to go
somewhere even though I'm not religious
I have a sense those last few minutes
involve a soul and a scale and I live my
life accordingly just in
case thank you so much for hanging out
with us today my name is AJ that sackle
fish step into the light there is peace
and serenity in the light this has been
the wi files if you had fun or learn
anything do him a favor subscribe
comment like share that stuff really
helps him out and like most topics we
cover on the channel today's was
recommended by you so if there's a story
you'd like to see or learn more about go
to the Y files.com stips remember the
yfiles is also a podcast twice a week I
post deep dives into the stories we
cover here on the channel I also post
episodes that wouldn't be allowed on the
channel they're called unredacted so
it's the wi files operation podcast
available everywhere you get your
podcasts now if you want more wi files
in your life check out our Discord there
are thousands of people on there 24/7
and they're into the same weird stuff
that we are it's a great Community it's
a lot of fun and it's free to join now
special thanks to our patrons who make
this channel possible every episode of
the wi files is dedicated to you I
couldn't do this without your support
and if you'd like to support the channel
consider becoming a member on patreon
for as little as three bucks a month you
get access to perks like you see the
videos early with no commercials you get
access to merch only available to
Members Plus you get two private live
streams every week just for you another
great way to support the channel is grab
something from the Wi-Fi store grab one
of these Heckle fish t-shirts and then
get a fishable coffee mug and put some
coffee in there and drink it while
you're wearing one of these Heckle fish
hoodies and then squeeze a stuffed
animal Heckle fish tuet fish toy while
you're playing a game or go Heckle fish
card games that's going to do it until
next time be safe be kind and know that
you are
[Music]
appreciated
yeah I play Bia inara 51 a secret code
inside the Bible said I
was I love my UFOs and paranormal fun as
well as music so singing the like I
should another conspiracy theory becomes
the truth my
friends and it never
ends no it never
[Music]
ends I feel the crap cat I got stuck
inside M's hole with MK truck I feel on
to
aw did Stanley CU Bri fake the Moon
standing alone on a film set with the
shadow people
there well aliens gets Fought The
Smiling man I'm
told and his name was
cold I
can't I'm dancing with the
fish fish on thday night wedn
J all through the
night all what it was to just hear the
truth so one Fe all through the
[Music]
night the MTH man sidings and the solar
storm still come to have got the the
secret
underground mysterious number stations
Planet are to project State and where
the dark Watchers
found we in a simulation don't you worry
though the black KN satellited told me
so I can't believe I'm dancing with the
fish fish on Thursday night with they J
and
all through the
night all I ever wanted was to just give
the truth
the all through the
night fish thday night with they J you
and my all through the
night all I ever want it was to just
hear the truth so the one timeat all
through the
[Music]
love love Dan good Dan good dance good L
to
Dane loves to dance on the dance ball
because she is a camel and camel love to
dance when the feeling is right on in
time
dir love the SC
[Music]
love